Okay. So, uh welcome to another week of
uh AA 203. Um so, starting from our
usual road map in the last week or so,
we have started basically we finished
the optimal uh base uh optimal control
part of the class and we moved into the
top half which basically relates with
learning based methods for optimal
control. Uh last week we focused a lot
on uh well on Monday we focused on more
classical methods to learning based
control. So we looked at things such as
system identification and adaptive
control. And then uh on last week
Wednesday we started to introduce the
general framework and terminology for
imitation learning and reinforcement
learning and kind of starting to build a
bit of a mental model about how to see
different methods and different
algorithms within these two uh subasses.
And so specifically today, we'll then
zoom into the specifically imitation
learning section of of what we discussed
on uh on Wednesday.
And so if you remember, we basically
introduced imitation learning as uh uh
basically a an umbrella term that
encompasses broadly speaking kind of two
main classes of approaches. We started
from uh behavior cloning as essentially
a mechanism where we want to have
access. So we take we always assume we
have access to a data set of um couples
of states and controls which we
collected by observing some expert uh
kind of executing some demonstrations in
the real world for example.
And then in behavior cloning we want to
use this data set to uh kind of directly
learn a policy uh or approximate the
policy that is being used by the expert.
Uh concretely the object that we wish to
learn will be something along the lines
of a policy pi of theta uh for example a
parameterized policy with some
parameters theta that is essentially
representing a distribution over
controls given states and we want to
approximate this from the examples that
we get in our demonstrations.
We then also uh loosely introduce
inverse reinforcement training whereby
in this case the objective is to
approximate the reward function or
objective that is optimized that we
think is being optimized under the hood
by the expert itself.
And specifically here the object of
learning will be to approximate or
estimate a reward function R that is
basically a measure that uh maps uh
couples of states and controls to a
scalar measure of success.
And so for today kind of co coherent
with this with this general road map
we'll be uh discussing behavior cloning
first we'll be introducing a number of
common pitfalls uh which we already
slightly hinted to in uh in our last
lecture on Wednesday and specifically I
would say um starting to look at
traditional mechanism for which these
pitfalls are being addressed
um and then we'll have a brief mention
on other paradigms that fall within the
behavior cloning
um hat and then we'll look at inverse
enforcement learning.
So just to uh briefly recap in one slide
the lecture from Wednesday we started by
seeing behavior cloning essentially as
supervised learning of behavior right so
we introduced the general notation of
supervised learning whereby we
essentially want to learn a parametric
mapping that maps some inputs x to some
outputs y. uh kind of uh prototypical
example would be the classification
problem where we want to map some image
representation. For example, an RGB
image, an RGB that represents the image
of a cat to the its label with of the
respective object or thing that is
actually being represented in that
image. And the way to do this is by
taking a data set of pairs of of this
mapping that we want to estimate and
then learn it through some sort of uh
loss minimization.
In behavior cloning, we want to do
something very similar to some extent
because we want to collect a data set of
these expert demonstrations and exactly
as we would be doing in supervised
learning, we'd want to train a policy
that is this mapping that uh optimizes
some metric of performance. And so we
saw how kind of the general skeleton of
behavior cloning algorithm loosely
speaking really looks like something
like take supervised learning and now
applied to trying to estimate behavior.
So but but the the question here is is
this really it right does this work or
are we done and in practice as you can
imagine uh most of the times this is not
it in the sense that there are a number
of common pitfalls and failure modes
that could happen. And so today we'll
basically be looking at strategies to
address these failure modes. And I would
say look at different techniques that uh
kind of frontier approaches specifically
in learning based control and robotics
are are currently doing to um to make
these techniques work.
Okay. And so let us start from
introducing the common pitfalls that
that could emerge. And the first one is
the one of uh compounding errors.
Specifically uh we mentioned multiple
times how in statistical learning theory
kind of a classical assumption that is
made is that data is independent and
identically distributed or iid for
short. Loosely speaking this means that
we are taking some um distribution of p
of x which we wish to approximate. To do
this we only have access to samples or
realizations of that distributions x1 to
x3 here on the slide. And we want to
learn typically a parametric model that
approximates this P of X that we carry
in learning. And we saw that again
generally speaking in statistical
learning theory we assume that the
samples and realization that we observe
are IID from the distribution that we
care about in when trying to learn
behaviors. However, kind of predictive
controls influence the future states
that we observe. And we loosely and
briefly discussed this idea of the fact
that since we are agents within our
environment, there could be this problem
and issue of compounding errors whereby
if our policy is making even very small
errors, it could compound over time that
is throughout the uh temporal kind of
unrolling of our trajectory which lead
to making bigger and bigger errors over
time.
Slightly more formally uh kind of theory
here formalizes this problem as the fact
that the state distribution induced by
the expert policy and the state
distribution induced by the learner that
is the policy that we we wish to to
learn essentially diverge and are not
the same and this is in in theory
referred to as the coariate shift uh
problem. So to make the notation on the
slide more concrete when we say the
distribution the state distribution are
under the expert that is P of expert
of X. What we're essentially saying is
for example the probability of the
initial state times the product T that
goes from one to T of the expert policy
you. So the probability over the action
induced by the expert policy given the
state xt times the uh transition
function of our environment.
Right? So this is basically encodes the
probability distribution of all the
states that we could observe by
following the policy or the distribution
of our actions induced by the expert.
Very similarly kind of the
state distribution under our policy P of
U pi theta would essentially be designed
ex defined exactly the same where here
we just used the distribution over
controls induced by the policy that we
are uh that we're currently learning
and there is so there's this I would
definitely advise you to check out this
this reference here on the slide
um because there is theory that
basically shows that um the probability
of making mistakes
um under our policy essentially grows
quadratically with the length of the
trajectory. So here assuming that there
is a probability epsilon to make a
mistake in our prediction from our
policy uh then the uh probability of
making mistakes grows quadratically with
the length t of our trajectory.
Of course here the error kind of assumes
that we are working in a discrete world
where we have to pick between one of n
possible actions and epsilon is the
probability of making an error in that
prediction but there is a lot of theory
that goes about formulating this co
shift problem more theoretically but I
hope the intuition here it's clear yes
or
uh the trajectory itself are
independent. Yes,
>> you have
>> this is a good question. So in general
for now and I would say throughout the
rest of the this lecture we're assuming
that you're interested in learning the
feedback policy. So there is a mapping
from the instantaneous state XT to the
instantaneous control UT. And our data
set therefore is just a collection of
tupoles of this realization.
Okay.
And so this is for the compounding error
uh problem. A second problem is the one
that here I refer to as multimodel
behavior. [snorts] And specifically uh
in many tasks uh there is this uh kind
of you know there is this
characteristics whereby there are there
could exist multiple and equivalent
solutions to solving a control task
right. So take the pictorial example of
flying a drone past a tree here on the
slide. uh if you know we were to be
human experts or human that are kind of
joysticking this uh drone around we
would be in a situation where you know
flying to the right or to the left of
the tree would be equivalently good to
some extent
and the problem here arises in when we
want to take this data set of collected
demonstrations from for example human
rollouts
and use these data sets to kind of
compile or learn a policy that tries to
approximate uh this behavior
slightly more formally. The problem here
is that we find ourselves in our
situation whereby the uh policy that we
wish to estimate is actually
representing a multimodel distribution
over controls given states.
For example, like in this case, we might
want our policy p of theta to perfectly
approximate this bodel distribution over
here.
And the problem here emerges in the
moment where we for example try to
estimate things or kind of fit this
distribution through pretty standard
metrics for example mean squared error
minimization. And the point is that if
we were to take uh say a neural network
and try to fit our data through mean
squed error minimization we would be
essentially learning a policy that tries
to uh predict exactly the mean of our
distributions. Right? So
what we're saying is that we are in a
situation where we would like to
approximate a ground truth behavior uh
uh distribution that looks something
like this. That is my model. But if we
were to use mean squed error as our loss
for a model for for data fitting, we our
policy would then be uh incentivized to
learn something that correctly predicts
the mean of this multimodel
distribution. And you see how in this
case this is actually probably the worst
thing that we could do because it fits
exactly in the middle because it tries
to kind of balance out errors between
both both modes.
And this is actually a problem that is
extremely common in practice. For
example, just consider where we are
collecting data from from multiple
experts which might behave differently
in the same condition. And so this is
something that we will have to uh to
take care of.
Does this make sense? any any questions
on this?
Okay.
And so for the rest of today, we'll
basically be building uh what I'm
calling here a useful mental model for
it tries to for basically developing
techniques that are remedies for for
these issues. Specifically, we'll be
looking at um algorithms which basically
try to address these problems
specifically or at least from an
algorithmic standpoint. We'll be looking
at uh ways in which we could address
these problems from a data collection uh
perspective and then we'll see we'll be
seeing how we can use expressive model
classes to better represent the
distribution of our data. And so
specifically the first two bullet points
here on the slide that is targeted
algorithms and uh data collection will
be focusing on the compounding errors um
kind of issue while the third one will
focus on the multimodality of our uh
policy in our data.
Okay. So let us start from the uh first
one. algorithms that try to specifically
devise methods to to target these these
issues
and um very important aspect which I I
want to highlight is the is essentially
the the value that there is in
corrective data. So until now we're
basically discussing a situation where
we are collecting data from an expert
which and we are always kind of hinted
at this uh fact where we basically want
to compile the performance of our expert
into a learned model a parametric
function and we always said that the
performance of our model is at least at
the kind of ideally as good as the
quality in our data. And so kind of it
it probably came as a as a following
thought. The fact that we want to keep
our data kind of the best possible,
right? So we want to collect
demonstrations that are exceptionally
good in solving the the task. The
problem is that if we do so, most likely
we'll be uh ending up with a data set
that is extremely narrow around a
specific kind of behavior in solving
that task.
And if you if you wish kind of this kind
of leads to the
um uh kind of a counterintuitive fact
because in general if we want to apply
kind of behavior cloning um to our
learning based control problem.
There is a lot of value in leveraging
examples of errors u that have been
taken by the experts and ways to
recovers from those errors because in
practice whenever we deploy our policies
in the real world the policy will be
making some errors and so if we have an
extremely perfect data with no errors
whatsoever in those states where the
policy actually makes errors it will
have no clue of how to uh recover from
those errors. And so there is this
paradox whereby learning from a broader
set of trajectories that makes some
mistakes but also shows ways to correct
from these mistakes is in general more
valuable than learning from a narrow set
of perfect demonstrations.
And one way to kind of automate this um
labeling and collection of corrective
data is uh through an algorithm is known
as dagger. Um and specifically dagger is
a well-known method to address this
coarate shift problem through what are
called data aggregation techniques which
is also where the the name comes from.
And I think it's probably useful to go
through um a pseudo code of uh how at
least the plain version of Dagger looks
like and then we uh we discuss this a
little bit more in detail. And
specifically in Dagger we start from an
initial data set of expert
demonstrations things that we have
collected by running some policy in the
wild or observing some human. We'll have
an initial policy pi theta superscript
one where here the superscript refers to
the number of iterations of the dagger
algorithm. So dagger will be an
iterative algorithm where we are
iterating from one to n iterations and
so here the superscript refers to the
policy that is derived at iteration i.
So um indeed so what Dagger does is we
start our iterations and for each of
these iterations we will be collecting
some trajectories taile uh which
basically represent the uh couples of
states and controls which we observe by
letting the learner policy interact with
our environment. So we have a given
policy, we let it interact with the
environment and we collect data from
these rollouts.
Um what we want to do is then we want to
take these states that we have visited
during our rollouts and in these states
we want to query our expert for
reabeling. that is we want to take those
same states XT and for those states we
want to re label the control that was
originally uh taken from the learner
with the control uh from the expert.
Once this is done we have a new version
of our data set the superscript I and we
aggre aggregate it with the original
data set which we had for for learning
and so this is where the aggregation
part comes from. We then take this
aggregated data set D and use this to
train a new version of our policy.
Right? So maybe slightly more visually
we are saying that we have um a policy
pythea one given to us. This could have
been given to us by an offline data set
that we have and trained on this.
>> [snorts]
>> We then have our environment which might
look like something where we want to go
from some starting points to some goal
points
where we are seeing examples of rollouts
of our policy
and and and this leads to a data set of
states and controls where the controls
are the ones uh that the learner
executed.
So we can then use these this data set
to basically relabel those controls
with controls given by the expert.
This creates a new data set the
superscript I which we aggregate it to
the previous one and train on the
updated uh data set. So why is this uh
useful? The problem the like the point
here is that by doing so we are directly
querying the expert to reabel states
exactly in those states where uh that
are currently being visited by the
learner itself. Right? So we were
talking about this discrepancy between
uh the distribution of a states induced
by the learner and the one induced by
the expert. In this case, we are
explicitly querying the expert in those
states that are that would be followed
and are essentially drawn from the state
distribution under the learner.
Yeah.
>> Are you justing there as a successful
control and then reabeling it as an
expert and retraining that now that as
the expert or training it from your
original expert? Um uh so here we are
assuming we have access to an expert
that we can query. Uh this could be any
policy that we think is good enough for
us to be an expert and we are using this
to basically generate new label data for
us in some way.
>> Does it make does it answer your
question?
>> Yeah.
>> Yes. In practice, if the [clears throat]
source of the expert policy is a human,
is this kind of like a discrete process
where you would have to like step
through because if you want the exact
same states, do you have to like step
through and like not continuously
provide input but like go like state to
state to state and provide the screen
input and then that is the releabeling
process.
>> Yeah, it's a great question because this
is like if you wish like one version of
this is like you would see dagger v
0ero, right? So this is the base version
of dagger. There is an extension to this
which is referred to as human gated
dagger. Uh whereby which will be in the
next slide which where basically here we
would be picking a specific point in our
trajectory where we think the maybe the
learner made the mistake and here we
assume we have a human that basically
intervenes and generates a new full uh
kind of continuation of that trajectory.
Concretely kind of you have a robot arm
that is doing some task. uh you're
physically looking at the arm while it's
doing things. But here you're seeing
that maybe it's you know it's spilled
over something and so you're taking over
and from there you're maybe
teleoperating the arm to generate a new
trajectory
>> and in that case you would be limiting
the augmented data set to have the exact
same states as the original and you
allow yourself to like explore a
different part after the mistake.
>> Yeah. Which in a way um this is a nice
segue because if you think about it this
is only one iteration of the algorithm
but if you repeat this then you're
basically you will be having rollouts of
a new policy pi 2 which has a different
state distribution right and so here you
will be covering new set of states so
kind of very high level kind of dagger
is an automated way to take your given
policy you uh let it interact in your
environment and you basically expose
failure modes instead, [snorts] right?
You basically follow what the policy
will be doing and you correct those
failure modes. Once you've done this,
you might be maybe creating new failure
modes or you might be just observing new
failure modes and you keep iterating
this process.
Okay. And so essentially kind of Dagger
really operates as a form of iterative
uh supervised learning because we're
using supervised learning as this inner
learning component but we're really
creating this iterative scheme where we
query the expert um from in order to
reabel states that are based under
evolving versions of the policy itself.
And if you think about it kind of at a
high level, what we're saying here is
that we are you can see Dagger as a data
efficient way of querying the expert
because we we're saying we want to use
the expert as a mechanism to
uh generate corrective behavior when the
policy fails. And in this way we are
directly probing the expert exactly on
those states that are visited by the
policy where it fails. Right? So here we
are basically following the state
distribution under the policy seeing
where where it failed and reabeling
which is a pretty data efficient way of
collecting these uh corrective
behaviors. kind of the other extreme
would be that in order to collect all
[snorts] the corrective behaviors that
you care about, you would have to run
this maybe on kind of all the possible
states that your policy uh would ever
encounter and re label everything which
is extremely expensive.
So this is in a way pretty data
efficient but quering the expert
depending on your scenario is in general
something very expensive. So again
depending on the task dagger might or
might not be something feasible.
And so here we looked at the naive
version of dagger but there are
different ways that uh you can maybe
modify the basic algorithm. One could be
uh confidence-based methods whereby here
we are quering the expert on basically
all the states that the policy visits
during those rollouts. But we could
maybe select some metric of uncertainty
from the learner itself and only query
the expert on those states where the
learner was particularly uncertain about
its answer. The other mechanism is also
as your colleague was referring to is
this human gated dagger where we have
some humans that are kind of supervising
the operation of uh our learner and
directly intervening uh when there is a
mistake.
>> Yes. So if you don't is the benefit of
this like trying to make like a lighter
weight policy because you have an expert
policy already but you're not using it
for some reason. So this makes it like
runs faster online
>> for example that would be one way. So I
would say
in general like if you kind of zoom out
in all the methods that we're seeing in
this class I would say all of these are
relevant although definitely there is
being a shift towards a learning based
or more end to end uh architectures.
Um the point is that kind of getting
reliable data for these end-to-end
architecture nowadays I would say even
in frontier models typically relies on
some more classical approach to generate
labels for those and so in some way you
could see this as a way of distilling
some maybe extremely expensive you know
uh indirect method for optimal control
into a fast uh neural network that can
approximate it. Yeah.
Okay, any questions on on Dagger before
before me we move on?
Okay,
so we saw how Dagger is one example of
an algorithm that directly tries to
target these uh collar shift issues. uh
let us look at how we could do this
through uh data collection and I want to
do this through uh two case studies and
going through two examples of this. So
in this case this was I think one of the
early works from Nvidia on autonomous
driving. I think it dates back around um
2016.
What they basically try to do is uh
learn uh
uh a neural network uh for um basically
deciding uh kind of the steering angle
of the car uh while receiving as input
some uh images coming from some uh uh
cameras that were mounted on on on board
the the car.
And
let's see. Yeah. So basically in this
study which again was uh now more or
less 10 years ago what you would see
they started from something which was
clearly not working uh also maybe being
a little bit dangerous. But then the
point of this work is that they started
collecting more data for uh for
basically more demonstrations of humans
driving cars and recording these couples
these tupils of images and steering
angle decisions. And they at the end
reached a performance that was to some
extent impressive especially at the time
and showed some pretty consistent uh
behavior. [snorts]
The point is that of course this was
pretty uh exciting at the time. Nowadays
we have made clearly some leaps from
this. uh but one thing that I want to
highlight from this work is um something
that you will observe if you read
through that paper and look at the
specific framework and architecture that
they uh they designed
specifically again as we were saying the
overall problem was taking some camera
images here they had three kind of a
center left and a right camera uh they
have some recorded steering wheel angles
from human drivers and the overall goal
was to learn a convolutional neural
network to basically basically learn to
you know approximate and predict those
steering wheel angles from the images
here I'm glossing over this box because
this is exactly the I think interesting
part from uh data collection uh
technique and specifically data
augmentation technique so again uh kind
of pictorially this is the kind of
situation we are in we have a car we
have our three uh cameras and we have
one recording of a steering wheel angle
right so the one that the human actually
um executed.
However, if we think about it a little
bit more closely, the two side cameras
could be used as an example of the car
slightly drifting off the center of the
lane. [snorts] And we could use these
observations to fictitiously augment the
data set with some steering angles that
that are actually seeing this camera uh
camera image and then correcting from
this camera image to kind of recenter
itself in the middle of the lane. Right?
So in general correcting data set of
driving mistakes is something that is
very dangerous and expensive. You don't
want to be collecting on purpose
corrective m data where you're driving
off the road and then going back again
on the road. And so in this work they
actually came up with this pretty neat
trick whereby they are augmenting the
data they collect from human drivers to
fictitiously generate these corrected
data by taking the uh side cameras as if
they were front cameras and manually
adjusting the steering angle for uh that
camera.
And so this is I think an example of how
you could try to embed this corrective
uh corrective behavior not from a
perspective of the algorithm but from
the perspective of data collection and
augmentation.
A very similar idea um um was also
presented in this work from the
University of Zurich where here uh the
the goal was controlling some uh
quadrotors to indeed um navigate some
hiking trails I think in the Swiss ops
or mountains um from camera images. The
setting is very very similar to some
extent. We have some image camera
specifically a front camera view and we
want to output this time a discrete
distribution over actions that is go
straight, turn left, turn right
and
once again very similarly what you see
in this work is something that really
resembles the previous work from uh
Nvidia where here you had the
researchers actually wearing this fancy
headband uh with I think three GoPros
mounted on
and collecting data by literally walking
uh over hiking trails and specifically
labeling um the [snorts] actions
according to those same augmentations.
Right? So here for the frontal camera
they were labeling it go as a go
straight action. For the left one they
were labeling it as a turn right and on
the right one they were labeling as a
turn left action.
[snorts]
Indeed, here's the the fancy headlamp.
And uh uh and so you would see that this
kind of works in practice. Uh and so
they got something that was at the time
pretty reliable in in navigating those
hiking trails.
Okay. And so here we saw two examples.
But I think the main message that I'm
trying to uh bring along is this idea
that we in trying to address co shift
from a data perspective, we want to be
intentional with data collection, right?
And specifically we want to
intentionally add mistakes and
correction for those mistakes in in our
data.
Um so this could be as in these examples
where we want to uh add some fake
demonstration of corrections. this
example of the side cameras or from an
algorithmic perspective we want to use
algor algorithms that automate the
collection of this corrective data as in
[snorts] as in dagger.
>> Yes. on the prior example the drone
[snorts]
made me wonder um when you're collecting
this data to train whatever model is
being used is it possible
to train like in the case
[clears throat] of the drone moving
training based on the decisions that are
being made like this is why you go left
and not the tree while also having it
not be relying on the dynamics that are
inherent to train data like the way that
a human moves with something on their
head
down
suddenly fly up two feet higher than you
are which for a drone you know that
might be advantageous or something take
advantage of things you can't do but if
they're trying data that comes from
something that's constrained to like
human dynamics
>> is there a way to detach the [laughter]
behavior of the drone from the dynamics
necessary sort of built into the data
that's trained on
>> I would say um not from the perspective
of imitation learning. So in imitation
learning we are
again at face value we are trying to
approximate and imitate the behavior of
some expert um and that's about it. So
we don't we don't really want to go
beyond what the expert is able to do. uh
and we typically won't have access to
data that is beyond what the expert is
is able to uh experience. So in general
I would say no. Uh this will probably be
something uh that will be extremely
relevant from the perspective of
reinforcement training where there we
are not trying to approximate some
behavior that is being shown to us by
some experts but we want to interact
with that environment maybe a simulator
of um of the real world and experiment
with different strategies. Yeah. Yeah.
[clears throat]
Okay. And so um so we covered it uh we
covered algorithms, we covered uh data
collection. Let us look at uh using
expressive models uh to address or
partially solve um the issue that comes
with multimodel behavior.
And specifically we'll be looking at two
main classes of of methods. The first
one will be including history of
observations. Uh we'll see slightly uh
we'll see shortly in the next slide or
using expressive uh function classes to
better approximate and capture the
multimodality in our data.
So a brief mention on um using history
of observations is that until now and
you know whenever we are we framed the
MDP problem um theoretically we always
assume that the state is a perfect
representation and like you know
capturing all previous history in um in
our system. In reality, especially if we
are working with, you know, images, we
won't be dealing with the ground truth
full state representation of our system,
but we will most likely be dealing with
observations of the system, right? Which
are only partial informations or partial
observations of the actual system. And
so in this case um there is benefit uh
sometimes depending on the applications
on rather than defining a policy as a
distribution over actions given the
instantaneous observation uh xt in
adding a sequence of past observations
to our context. Essentially
in the case of behavior cloning, this is
particularly relevant in the case where
we're maybe collecting data of these um
to both states controls from humans
demonstrations. Because if you think
about it here, if we try to learn this
uh policy from data, we are basically
assuming that the human that has been
collecting data for us given the same
observation will always behave in the
same way. Right? On the other hand,
history could be an interesting
confounding factor to basically add to
our context to differentiate between
different observations.
Again, let's make a concrete example.
Say that we our X for us is just the
front camera of our car and U is our
steering angle. Then if X is only one
snapshot of the current history, we
basically have no idea of maybe the
speed of our car or any other relevant
measure of uh that could be useful for
decision- making and we are implicitly
assuming that given the same uh kind of
front car camera image we would be
always behaving in the same way. On the
other hand, if we assume to have a
history of previous camera images, then
we might be capturing more useful
information for for decision- making.
In practice, um, this is typically
handled through basically your favorite
sequence model where could be
transformers, could be recurring neural
nets or something of the sort where, uh,
the policy then basically be becomes
something that takes a sequence of
states or observations and outputs the
uh, next action. So again, pretty uh,
pretty high level discussion, but I
think it's worth worth mentioning in
practice. uh I would say also my
experience with uh with including
history in defining uh the behavior
policies is usually very empirical. So
you you will be doing some sort of
ablation where you're maybe uh trying
out the training your policy on your
same data set with uh varying number of
uh history time steps in the past and
seeing what works best.
Okay. Um but let's let us move to I
think something that is more uh
fundamental which is the this issue of
wanting to capture the full data
distribution. Right? So we made before
this example of the drone flying past
the tree and we could have these two
equivalent solution modes or behavior
modes for our policy.
And so the goal for us rather than
fitting this mean value of this
potentially multimodel distribution what
we want to do is represent the entire
distribution.
And to do so uh let us briefly revisit
what it actually means for um [snorts]
for us to parameterize or deise a
parametric function to express full
distributions. And this will loosely
depend on whether the distribution that
we want to um output is discrete. So
something like a categorical
distribution over a finite set of
possible actions. Say the four cardinal
directions moving up, down, left or
right. Or if this is continuous, it
could be something like uh capturing the
mean and the standard deviation of what
our desired steering angle is. In
practice, how we do this is we would say
that we wish to define a neural network
that outputs these parameters of our
distributions. We could either have a
neural net output the logits or the
individual probabilities for each of our
discrete actions or we could have a
neural net that basically represents the
mean and standard deviation of a
candidate gausion over kind of possible
steering angle commands.
The benefit of the discrete distribution
is that it naturally handles
multimodality.
Right? So say that
again this is the
distribution that we wish to um have our
model output in. If we discretize this
naturally continuous state into bins
and then assign a probability to each of
those bins that sums up to one, we might
be very well able to uh capture this
multimodality by learning something uh
of the sort.
Right? So discret discretized
representations are actually very
powerful because they it's something we
can do very well. So we could just learn
this through cross entropy which is
pretty standard in supervised learning
and get out of this something that
naturally represents multimodel
distributions.
At the same time, uh I I think pretty
obvious downside is that depending on
the dimensionality of our output and the
discretization that we're interested in
and that is maybe relevant for our
application, the we could have a lot of
bins to to and a lot of probability um
kind of logits to u to estimate and so
this scales poorly with the
dimensionality of our action space. In
this case,
the pro of using kind of a continuous
distribution as our output
representation is obviously that this
naturally captures the continuous nature
of our actions. So no discretization uh
required. Uh but this might not be very
expressive, right? So if we wish to use
a gausian and we want to fit a gausian
to this uh real underlying biodal
distribution then probably what we will
learn is uh something like this right
and this is because we are trying to
represent a biodal distribution through
a unimodal distribution.
Does this make sense? Any any questions
or doubts here?
>> Is there like scaling or continuous
distribution as well?
>> Sorry. like for higher dimensional
distributions. So like scale
>> the continuous distribution of course
depending on the um distribution that
you care about this might or might not
scale well in general like say we are
just looking at an n dimensional
gausian. This is pretty compactly
represented by a mean vector and a
coarance matrix uh which might be much
cheaper compared to having a bin uh in n
dimensional space.
>> Yeah.
>> And could you also just account for
different loads by just adding more
sigma on like rasrees?
>> Yes, exactly. So this is a great segue
to the next slide. Um
[laughter]
>> and uh so the in the point is so these
are ways of uh representing uh
distributions. Um how can we be more
expressive in representing multimodel
distributions. One example could be as
you were exactly saying let's fit a
gausian mixer model to our data. Uh what
is a gausian mixer model or GMM for
short is that we're basically defining
rather than a single unimodel gausian we
want to learn the parameters of a
mixture of gausian distributions which
is usually comprised by k gausian. So we
will be defining the mean and um
coariance matrix for each of those k
gausians together with a waiting factor
uh or these k waiting factors w1 to w k
which basically define the weighted
average of these individual gions.
Right? So in practice the gausian
mixture distributions are um quite
powerful and expressive because through
uh gausian we can easily approximate uh
potentially complex uh functions right.
So we could have indeed um kind of these
three gapions being somehow combined
through appropriate choice of the
weights to maybe measure to represent a
distribution that is extremely non
non-unimodal. Right?
A caveat of course in general models is
that the choice of K is a hyperparameter
and has to be chosen in advance. Um
again this is usually something pretty
empirical that is you just try different
numbers of K and see what uh what works
best. The trade-offs here could be uh
the usual ones that come with respect to
overfitting and underfitting of data. If
I have very high K, I might be fitting
very well my training data but this
doesn't really generalize to my um
testing data or inference.
Or we could define K based on some
domain knowledge, right? So we may know
that the policy actually has three
distinct modes and so we might just pick
that as K. But in general it's a
hyperparameter.
Uh a second class of um approaches to
represent uh or expressive ways of
representing multimodal distributions is
what I'm referring to here as the
discretise plus autogressive approach.
So we introduced before this idea of uh
discretization uh to represent
multimodel distributions but we
mentioned that scaling this to
highdimensional actions for us or in
general high dimensional distributions
could be expensive.
Again, I think a nice visualization
could be something where [snorts]
say that we have our a two-dimensional
distribution that we wish to estimate.
The discretization in this case would
essentially be equivalent to picking a
discretization in our two-dimensional
space and having to pick a specific
value for each of these grid cells.
You see how this scales uh very badly
and specifically not only does it scale
badly in the sense of number of
parameters that we that we want to
estimate. It also um clearly suffers
from the curse of dimensionality when we
look at uh model learning. And this is
because in reality we only be estimating
our distribution from samples from our
underlying distribution, right? And so
in order to populate all of the grid
cells, you see how we would need an
exponentially large number of samples
from our distribution. So a nitric is
the one of basically decomposing uh auto
reggressively this um this
two-dimensional uh distribution.
What does this mean? In general, uh we
could uh represent exactly a joint
distribution over um
x1 and x2
as the
basically the product
of the conditional distribution x1 times
the so the probability of x1 times the
probability of x2 given x1.
And this is an exact uh reformulation,
right? So we're not losing anything. Uh
but what we're gaining is that rather
than having to uh discretise uh n
dimensional space, we only do
one-dimensional discretizations. Right?
So in practice, this would mean
something like we only need to
discretise the onedimensional version uh
vector.
So this would be like P of X1 and this
would be P of X2 given X1
and only have to learn these two uh
one-dimensional discretized
representations.
And here not only this is more efficient
from the perspective of total total
parameter count, it is also more
efficient with respect to the course of
dimensionality issue that we were
describing because here while this the
samples in this 2D grid are pretty
sparse, the same four samples would be
clearly denser in these one-dimensional
vectors, right?
Because we would be using the same four
samples something like that.
In practice, this is exactly what people
do when using transformer models for uh
robot policies. So in this case, you
would be your um one-step probability
distribution would just be the
transformer. You would have some context
which could be maybe some camera image,
maybe some natural language prompts that
describe your task. and you're learning
your distribution over next element in
that sequence. Um where this could
essentially be again let us look at this
more visually. So in natural language in
in LLMs you typically have you know some
transformer block
that takes an input like
>> [snorts]
>> u
a token here uh maybe a sequence of
those and basically predicts the next
token in that sequence right we can just
call it uh maybe xt in order to predict
this then you would be auto reggressive
ly introducing
the predicted XT here, predict XT + one
and so forth kind of doing this auto
reagive prediction. Um here we would be
taking this exact framework that is we
only learn this one step uh prediction
rule where XT rather than being tokens
or words in uh as you would do in LLM
here the XT could be one dimension of
our action right so if if we have an
action vector
a Q that is comprised of like a a
steering angle
and an acceleration
We might have uh this deco composed such
we that we first predict the steering
angle and then we feed the steering
angle to our back to our model and
predict the acceleration. Does that make
sense?
>> Yes.
>> You still have to go through understand
before you can run this online
[clears throat] and narrow things down.
I would say in terms of dimensionality,
no. But here you're basically trading
off a kind of ease of representation
with compute because now you would not
be sampling all at once, but you're
sampling autogressively. So in order to
generate the full vector, which might
be, you know, n dimensional, you would
have to do n steps and calls to your in
this case transform block.
Okay. Again, so this is uh very uh very
popular in practice. Um another class of
u models uh also very popular especially
over the last couple of years um is
basically relates with diffusion
processes and diffusion models and even
more recently I would say over the last
couple of years um flow matching. And
the idea of diffusion in general is that
so we're saying we want to sample from
you know a potentially complex
distribution.
Uh but we don't obviously we don't know
how to sample from this uh potentially
wild distribution.
But in general we might have some easy
distribution say a gausian
from which we know exactly how to to
sample and this is easy. And so in
diffusion processes in general kind of
cast uh the problem as wanting to
transform a sample from a simple
distribution which we know how to sample
from and then transform these samples
such that they match the target
distribution that we care about
learning. [snorts] And so in practice uh
what diffusion um typically defines is a
process whereby we at sampling time we
would go from noise to the actual
realization that we that we care about.
So we want to learn uh this
transformation
diffusion models uh were originally
introduced for generating images. So I
would say nowadays basically any image
generation out there is using some form
of diffusion model or a flow matching
representation. Um and the goal here is
to map from pure noise given some
conditioning for example you know
generate an image of a cat uh to the
actual uh image that we care about
generating. So the sampling direction is
pretty straightforward. We want to take
noise. we have a learned um
kind of transformation and we use this
to gradually and iteratively the noise
uh going from noise to actual image. The
tricky one and interesting is of course
the uh backward direction, right? So how
do we learn how do we learn this
mapping? In practice for uh diffusion
models, this is done by learning this
individual uh denoising step. So you
what you would do is you would take your
data set of images and define kind of
gradually more noisy versions of those
images, right? So we would take like x0
and then define kind of x0 plus some
noise and then define and this would be
x1
and then we define x1 plus some noise.
This would be x2. And so we gradually
generate more and more noisy versions of
this image until we get pure noise.
And the goal in diffusion models, we
then want to approximate uh these this
noise term to basically being able to
reverse the process. Right? So at data
generation time, we basically have the
forward gener the forward generation
where we just add noise to our image and
then we want to approximate this noise
through a learned parametric mapping f
of theta which then allows us to go in
the reverse direction.
Again, I'm aware this is pretty handwavy
description uh but I'm happy to provide
references for diffusion models in
practice. But the bottom line here is
that diffusion models and flow matching
models are extremely uh powerful ways of
representing these multimodel uh
distributions.
Um but let us look a little bit more
closely to into flow matching. And the
idea is that if in diffusion models we
are interested in learning this error
term epsilon, this noise term epsilon to
be able to reverse the um the kind of
the denoising process in flow matching.
What we want to learn essentially is a
vector field to do this iterative
denoising. So we're basically describing
this um statistical transport problem
where we want to move samples from a
simple noise distribution into samples
from a potentially uh complex uh
distribution.
So in practice at inference the way this
goes is that assume we have learned a
vector field v of theta.
At inference, we would be sampling a
point x0 from our noise distribution and
[snorts] then we would kind of
generating u a data point from our
target distribution essentially entails
integrating forward this vector field
and [snorts] we can do this through uler
integration for example.
Again kind of the caveat here is how do
we train and how do we learn this vector
field and at training time what we would
be doing is that we sample a couple. So
we would sample a sample um x0 from a
candidate initial distribution say a
gausian we would sample a point x1 from
our data set that is a sample from the
target distribution that care about
learning. We would sample a time step t
usually as a from a uniform distribution
between zero and one because we are
assuming that our kind of denoising step
goes from time zero to time one
and then in uh flow matching we
basically linearly interpolate between
these two points. This would essentially
mean kind of drawing a straight line
from our sample to the uh target sample
from the target distribution. And we
basically update the parameters of our
learned uh vector field such as to
minimize um the distance between our
prediction of the velocity essentially
with the target velocity between those
two points because x1 - x0 is
essentially the target velocity, right?
And so in practice, what this would
[snorts]
look like is something where we have our
easy distribution, say a normal
distribution here. We have our complex
distribution here. And what we would do
is we essentially learn a vector field
that kind of
you know guides us from every point
uh into
you know sampling from this other
distribution. Of course imagine this
vector field to be complete. But then in
practice we would be sampling from our
distribution and just integrating
forward for example through uler
discretization uler integration our our
samples to generate samples from this
other distribution.
And I would say flow matching is is is
very popular these days because it's
extremely powerful at representing
continuous distributions which are
ultimately what we care about in um
robot control for example.
Any questions here?
Okay.
A last trick that I uh wanted to make
sure we covered is the one of action
chunking. So um
until now and you know throughout this
course we've always been discussing kind
of uh feedback policy in the form of
um a distribution over next controls
given states. And so in general the
framework is something where we observed
some state xt we had some policy from
which which allows us to basically
sample an action uh in that specific
state. We would be executing this action
in the environment and then we would
observe a new state and repeat this
process.
And so visually this would look like uh
at all time steps from zero to seven we
would be generating one action executing
that in the respective time steps and
moving forward over time.
action chunking which I would say right
now is the most popular way of
parameterizing uh kind of robust
learning policies is something where
rather than predicting a single action
we are basically predicting actions over
a specific planning horizon of length K.
So if you wish this looks like something
like uh model predictive control right
so we're basically predicting K actions
in the futures and executing those K
actions um in our environment
um
so this became pretty popular first of
all because it tends to work quite well
so people just adopted it in general I
would say that a clear benefit is that
this allows more time for inference so
if we have premputed the actions for the
next k time steps then we can just trust
our predictions for the next k time
steps and only have to recomputee new
ones after k.
[snorts]
Another more subtle motivation for which
it is believed that these you know these
models perform and it's been shown that
these models perform better is that in
general these leads to smoother controls
uh control trajectories. So if you look
again at what we're doing here,
typically our policy pi would be a
learned object. So pi of theta and we
would be calling this object essentially
at each time step. And since this
learned policy might not be perfect, the
learning signal might be a little bit
jiggory because we might be we are
basically introducing some randomness at
every call. Right?
If we however predict a full uh
prediction sequence then kind of within
this short horizon sequence typically
the generations are more coherent uh
between it between each other and so
this leads to smoother controls which
typically are kind of deployed uh with
better performance.
But this is definitely another um trick
of the trade if you wish that that is
worth knowing about. [snorts]
And so some examples um this this work
uh the fusion policy uh was pretty
popular probably now dating back three
or four years ago. Um it was one of the
first examples of leveraging kind of the
fusion uh models and the fusion policies
at scale. Um so in general what you know
here we're going from an image um
representation observation of our state
uh and using diffusion models to
generate uh a full um
uh trajectory of behavior for our
robotic arm and it was shown to be able
to do extremely challenging tasks um
generalize across different conditions
and so the results here were um were
very good and exciting at the time. um
you will so not only are we using
diffusion models you'll also notice that
here we're using this action chunking
idea so we're generating a full
trajectory rather than a single action
and so this is definitely a work that
you know you I suggest you uh you go
check out
uh another example uh will be the kind
of robotics transformer series of works
um there have been follow-ups to this
work but at the high level here I wanted
to show the case where in general
general here we're learning a mapping in
the form of a transformer model that
maps from a history of images. So again
uh if you think back about our multiple
uh time steps multiple observations of
history and a language description of
the task that we wish to execute
to a discretized representation of our
action where we have been essentially
doing this discretization plus auto
reggressive uh generation. So here the
arm had different actions uh that it had
to um execute and we were basically in
this in this work they basically
generated each of these dimensions
individually and conditioning on the
previous one to do so.
So these are just examples of um the
topics that we have been discussing
today.
And so um at a high level kind of I
would say that you know we have been
touching these uh common pitfalls and
possible strategies to remedy for for
these pitfalls that range from
algorithms that were targeting those
pitfalls. For example, Dagger, we looked
at smart data collection and
augmentations.
take the three cameras and the
fictitious augmentations and we had kind
of a big parenthesis on how can we
represent the full distribution of our
data because this is ultimately what we
care about when learning from
demonstrations.
And so I would say that we have seen
behavior cloning um and kind of a a
usual a classical you know benefit and
pro of uh behavior cloning is that at
its core it's essentially supervised
learning right plus minus some kind of
deltas and I would say that supervised
learning is definitely easy to implement
and monitor. We have good metrics we
know it's usually well behaved from the
perspective of gradient descent and so
this is usually pretty simple to
implement. Um it's also pretty
efficient. So there is no need for trial
and error learning as we'll see starting
Wednesday in reinforcement learning. Um
and there is no need for an explicit
reward signal. So in some cases defining
a reward might be harder than learning
to um kind of devising a policy itself.
Take the case of driving. How do we
quantify numerically what good driving
is? On the other hand, learning a policy
to mimic expert demonstrations of
driving is actually much more
attractable.
On the cons side, um, of course, kind of
all of this, um, assumes that we have a
strong dependency on the quality of the
demonstrations. So, if the
demonstrations are bad, then there is no
way that the learned policy will be
good.
Uh, of course these strategies that we
discussed today are ways of addressing
kind of the compounding errors problems,
but these problems remain. Uh, and in
general, generalization of learned
policies is a is a big topic
and linked with the first one in
behavior cloning, there is no
exploration whatsoever, right? So we we
will have no way of discovering new
solutions for for for the task that have
not been um kind of demonstrated uh from
an expert. And so this is where kind of
reinforcement learning will will come in
the picture.
Okay. Any any questions on behavior
cloning?
Okay. So I want to quickly touch on a
couple of uh actually one other paradigm
for behavior cloning and then give some
pointers to uh inversion forcement
training uh methods.
So one interesting um idea um is that
[snorts] can we use kind of ideas from
behavior cloning to try to approximate
the objective of reinforcement learning.
That is can we go beyond the or at least
filter out
uh the performance of demonstrations in
our data set such that we are able to
get as close as possible to the best
kind of performance that has been shown
in the data set and potentially uh kind
of improve on it. And so the idea here
is that rather than um
relying on solely optimal demonstrations
for a specific task, we might want to
leverage a broader set of demonstrations
um for example from suboptimal policies
or related tasks or things of the sort.
um and slightly shift the learning
problem that we are uh positing in order
to uh to get the best from our data and
I would say two main classes of methods
are the filtering or waiting of
demonstrations or devising different
conditionings for our policy. So let us
go into the details because I think this
will be more um uh will be clear. So in
general we have been discussing the idea
of behavior cloning completely detached
from performance right we had no measure
of reward that was scoring how good the
trajectory was with respect to another
and so a kind of very simple idea is can
we introduce some of these uh
considerations by essentially
reintroducing the kind of the reward
function as a as a player in this game
whereby we might for For example, a
simple idea would just be doing
filtering. So say we have a reward
function that is able to score a
specific action in a kind of how good
was an action UT in a specific state.
This may allow us to score the quality
of entire trajectories because we could
just score we have a roll out in our
data set. We might just be summing up
the reward uh accumulated over this
trajectory and then we could basically
filter out our data set such to only
keep the trajectories that are better
than some uh value or uh bar that we
fix. Right? Um so here is a very simple
example in which we know that there is
performance in place. let us just focus
ourselves on the uh good ones on the
ones that are exceeding some threshold.
Another mechanism could be to do
waiting. So we have again some mechanism
of scoring uh our uh transitions and
trajectories through our reward. So let
us modify the learning problem for
example the uh maximum likelihood
estimation objective such that it
becomes a weighted version of the
original objective where the weights
come from the performer itself. Right?
So we don't want to mimic all
trajectories blindly. So maximize the
probability of all trajectories blindly.
But what we want to do is maximize the
the weighted probability where the
weight is essentially the performance.
Yes,
>> filtering the quoteunquote best
trajectories from what we were talking
about before where we want to like
purposefully on the suboptimal
trajectories.
>> Yeah, it's it's a very good question and
I would say that the answer here is very
case dependent. So it will really it'll
depend on the application that we're
that you're working with. Um,
I would say that these filtering
techniques are
particularly good in the case where you
have a very narrow task and where you
don't need to collect this uh corrective
behavior and but while here what you
care about is really focusing on I have
these very good trajectories and I want
to learn to um exploit them. This could
also be very good if your data set
quality is is just very broad. So maybe
I just have trajectories that are
extremely bad in here and and maybe my
data set is also extremely large and so
you have no ways of manually annotating
what is useful and what is not and so
you devise some simple strategy to
filter out uh bad things. Yeah. So I
would say it's kind of you know parallel
axis uh in devising your in kind of
towards your solution. Yeah.
Okay. And another idea is that um we
might want to enrich the kind of
conditioning that we do that we have in
our policy. So until now the policy for
us was you know distribution over
controls given states. Um but I think
two particularly popular um approaches
are to condition the policy on maybe a
candidate goal state for goal condition
policies uh or a candidate performance
that we wish we we'd have from our
model. So something where we might
condition it on a candidate uh total
reward for our trajectory.
Um why are these reformulations useful?
uh and I think this is can be easily
observed from the uh goal conditioned
one. So say that we have
uh some data set where we have you know
a number of trajectories say that go you
know from some x1 to some candidate xt.
Now maybe from the perspective of the
task this trajectory is very bad because
maybe XT is very different from the
actual goal uh that we had over here.
However, this is a good trajectory for
showing how we are reaching uh maybe
state Xi. Right? So if the goal is not
to solve a task but to reach a state
then every trajectory is a valid
trajectory for showing an example of how
we are reaching a candidate goal. Right?
So in our case this trajectory here
despite being bad for you know the task
of reaching this goal state learning
from this trajectory as a means of
having a general trajectory that could
reach any candidate goal. This is
actually a good thing to do. Right? So
in some way once we have learned this
goal reaching policy then the problem
becomes
um at inference I want to query my
policy to reach to reach a state that is
good for me right so I'm I'm I'm
basically learning a general mechanism
to reach any candidate goal point goal
state from my state and then at test
time I want to condition this policy on
reaching a state that is good for me
Right? [snorts]
But in this case, all trajectories are
useful with this regard because all
trajectories are good realizations of
reaching all the states along that
trajectory.
[snorts]
Okay. And same thing for reward
conditioning.
Okay. So just a quick mention on inverse
reinforcement learning. more than I
mentioned I would say pointers for you
to uh dive deeper if you're interested
um remember that in you know in behavior
cloning we wish to estimate the policy
that approximates or mimics the behavior
of an expert in inverse re reinforcement
learning we care about learning the
objective that is being optimized by the
expert
and in general I would say that so more
formally the goal of reinforcement
learning is to recover the reward
function which we think is being
optimized by the expert
Um in practice this means that we will
be often parameterizing a reward by some
parameters W and the goal is to find the
the values of those parameters that
better explain the expert
demonstrations.
There are a number of um inverse
enforcement algorithms as you can
imagine. But I would say that a high
level kind of the skeleton of most of
these algorithms is something like the
pseudo code here on the on the slide
whereby we will start from a data set of
expert demonstrations. And we will have
some initialized reward function
parameters W and policy parameters
theta.
And then most algorithms typically
alternate between two separate
processes. We'll have a first process
whereby we update the reward function
parameters according to some objective
and then we will use these
newly computed parameters W to optimize
for the parameters of the policy. So we
will have an estimate of W. We will use
this estimate to basically maximize the
policy with respect to that uh objective
and then use this policy to increase to
improve the estimate of W
again. So this is very high level
discussion but just to let you know that
most of these algorithms should be seen
from from this lens
and kind of popular algorithms are
apprenticeship learning maximum margin
planning and maximum entropy RL. So we
definitely start from those and these
algorithms at kind of to some extent all
try to address uh the the challenge or
one of the key challenges for uh inverse
reinforcement learning which is the one
of reward ambiguity.
And this is basically the problem where
um there could be many reward functions
that explain the same data. And so these
mechanisms really try to you know design
these two individual processes such that
we don't fall in this reward ambiguity.
Okay.
So just to conclude um we have been
introducing I would say most of the
techniques to basically build a mental
model I would say of how to deal with
imitation learning. We focus most of our
narrative on behavior cloning where kind
of the you know the vzero kind of naive
uh formalism of behavior cloning is that
we have a data set of expert
demonstrations and we want to learn a
mapping that approximates um the
behaviors in our data. We saw how this
um naive version is basically prone to
suffering from two main challenges
compounding errors and the multiodality
of behavior data. And we saw how we
could tackle this from a perspective of
data collection through smart
augmentations, a perspective of
algorithms, say Dagger, and expressive
models that try to capture the
multimodality of the of the data itself.
And then briefly mentioned two
alternative formulations such as
reinforcement uh learning through uh via
supervised learning and inverse RL.
Any questions on this? All
right, then. See you on Maz.